hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Ryan Ryan
today we're checking out the groovy teas
for ash versus evil debt oh yeah all
right
I'm sure this trailer is not gonna
feature anything but a groovy tease so
let's check it out and then maybe we'll
give some opinions on artistic Asian
thoughts afterwards he knows maybe yeah
interesting this isn't no one the trees
is it I don't [ __ ] know like months
ago okay no this just came out recently
all right all right all right all right
Wow what are those T's that is a that is
a T's that literally does not tell you
anything of what this new show is gonna
be like exactly but it's just the great
reassurance that Ash is back and he's
got the chainsaw well yeah it's not it's
not necessarily like telling us a whole
bunch about like intimate details but it
is telling us that stuff you want it's
right here yeah because army of Darkness
it ended you know well I don't know
there's not like two endings I guess
yeah yeah so but anyway when army of
Darkness was a really defining film for
Ashe you know like that's the image of
ash that we all left off with which was
kind of interesting to part threes that
establish the image yeah it's like Jason
3 is where we get the Jason we all know
like arguably Freddy 3 is kind of where
the jokey Freddy comes in true it's like
for some reason I didn't register the
ash would be back with a chainsaw and
shotgun possibly and you know it's
actually Bruce not proposes see Bruce
Banner
Bruce Campbell even know is actually
gonna be in the role which makes it that
much more rewarding oh yeah like that's
a way to bring a movie to a television
show you know like continue it cuz it's
not sorry for overwrite it's a
continuation I'm pretty sure yeah oh
yeah well yeah cuz he's older like there
and they're using that okay I think that
would yeah he's older and he's still a
stock boy at a smart okay Oh
did you think his army of darkness
wasn't the greatest received by critics
well because it's you know really
because it was so different shift yeah
it was so different but fans love that
[ __ ] movie well that's a movie that
probably gained a lot of love over time
oh absolutely
that is a cult classic that's actually
what introduce you to the Evil Dead
interesting yeah there's an interesting
fact period here I don't want them to
hold back on the gore no one there on
stars they can do pretty much whatever
they want and I hope they do it with
practical effects too because if they do
that I guess you know like I'm not a fan
of gore really I'm really not but when I
saw the remake of Evil Dead and even the
original like yeah when she gets the
pencil reticle yeah man this is really
really yeah but that even like the
demonic makeup looks [ __ ] amazing
well yeah and there's something about
that word it's like even in the first
movie where you know some of it you can
see the seams on things and it's a
little bit campy it's still really
unsettling for so II told it wasn't an
nc-17 I don't know yeah and then the
remake just [ __ ] took it to a whole
new extreme yeah which was [ __ ]
insane yeah but fifty thousand gallons
of blood but it was admirable for the
fact that it was practical effects so it
made it like more interesting to look at
even though it was like made it that
much more disturbing it may be well it
also made it fun and a release yeah
weird way yeah yeah I'm excited to see
the show it's cool I know Sam Raimi's on
board for it but so it's not Stafford so
to see that like the same people who
brought it to life are the ones
continuing it I'm excited to see what
they do I know it's not connected to the
remake so yeah yeah yeah yeah we got to
Evil Dead franchises yeah alternate
timelines yeah I'm deal dead to not
having something will change anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the real rejects
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Jerry's playlist on this
channel
Jerry it's a reason that's actually my
intellectual science by Jerry - easy
you'll follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter where if we get enough
followers we can
product placements meaning are you
rolling in boatloads of cash can I have
nothing for you yes oh you want some of
my product placement money no no look my
head I'm gonna say this to you without
saying